je vais démarrer par benjamin castaldi
qui connaît bien ce genre de gros bardot
alors honnêtement il s'en est très bien
tiré
j'avais dit dès le début que ya pas
beaucoup d espace moi j'ai trouvé plutôt
plutôt à l'aise sous vos débuts ce qui
est normal c'est la pression il a plutôt
été drôle après c'est pas le cas dit que
nous on a aimé ici c'est un camille un
peu plus posé c'était fin voilà il faut
que ce soit peuvent lui un peu plus
propre guillemets mais je pense qu'il va
trouver sa place si on le laisse à en
avoir plus à mon avis le format est
tellement également précisé des jeunes
s'amusent bien sensé me vois pas faire
beaucoup plus voir ça mais bien mathieu
et ben moi j'ai trouvé qu'il approuvait
enfin que dans ce genre d'émission
malgré tout avec un prompteur on n'a pas
de place tout ce qu'ils disent en a pas
de place et moi le premier parce que
j'en al iman sur nrj12 et j'étais pas
très bon bah tous ceux qui disent on n'a
pas de place prouve que quand ils ont du
talent on peut en trouver il en a
vraiment trouvé
donc voilà géraldine moi j'ai trouvé
excellent extrêmement bon camarade un
vent de fraîcheur je trouve qu'il a un
gradé complètement un rôle d'animateur
de cette émission et j'ai trouvé moi au
contraire qu'on reconnaissait le camille
combal qu'on a mis des frérots l'envoi
dé plusieurs reprises l'anglais de vous
aussi chers
frérot et anglais on est comme ça et
puis moi qui me fout complètement du
concours de danse fluide en a fait un
spectacle un peu érotique au comique toi
je roulais plutôt drôle un peu gothique
avec les élus mais qu'un poids poil
retrouvé sa taupe à mâcon a surtout qu'à
l'issue de leur garde mais il a surtout
retenu les rôtis coordination camille
samedi soir c'était un ringard au pdk
c'est parce que c'est un ami que je veux
pas être objectif et ça soit juste un
ami il rêverait dépoussiérer le
programme il l'a mis dans une bouteille
de formol il a tiré vers le bas c'est
plus chic du tout j'ai trouvé hyper
familier c'est une prestation
complètement raté et là je trouve que
c'est pas honnête de votre part vous
l'avez bien mais doit la vérité
alors là il est bon du tout madame jeu
savent plus mesuré évidemment il n'a pas
été mauvais il a fait du camille combal
comment on comme on les aime il a fait
ce qu'il a pu mais pour moi ça reste
encore un gachi et je trouve que c'est
pas son c'est pas son rôle c'est pas son
emploi et voilà donc su plus tristes de
le voir là dedans même si je trouve
qu'il a bien réussi mes jetons chômage
voilà je trouve dommage que je pense que
plein de gens je vous dirai ça alors que
lui un talent m'a beaucoup m'appeler
camille je vous dire ce qui m'a dit
exactement dans un instant historique
moi j'ai trouvé très maternant au
contraire et moderne franchement il
apporte un vent de fraîcheur sur le
programme et prouve qu'on peut oui des
ringards disais quelque chose qui est
très formaté et il a vraiment beaucoup
de talent il avait réussi à le décaler
légèrement programme sans en faire trop
et la grippe se décaler juste ce qu'il
faut alors une brémond pour une première
et ses succès une première emprunter
pour créer un fond d'huile il a fait du
camille combal comme on l'a connu ici
comme je les écoute le matin à la radio
il a fait ses vannes et les filles salut
les filles dans le public quand il dit
les trois petites vieilles c'est du
combat c'est que c'est excellent ce
qu'il a fait je vous mets au défi
d'aller faire des les âmes sur tel quand
même ils étaient beaucoup plus stressés
à la répète c'est pendant le direct ce
qui m'a dit non pas normal non
s'il croyait la tente finalement on
attend que jamais rien fait de sa
carrière
[Rires]
souriant spontanée et évidemment il un
peu ringarde et ses prédécesseurs ce
qu'il dit je suis la patronne a pas fait
assez il était juste prix alors c'est
tout